ANDERSSON GETS THE TKACHUK WITHF
THE POST!
THAT CLOSE TO OPENING THE
SCORIN DUCKS BLUE
LINE, LOOK AT THE BODY
CORNER, MANGIAPANE,.
HERE'S TREVOR LEWIS WITH A Soun]
[ Cheering ]N IT'S A
TWO-ON-ONE, GAUDREAU GETS IT TO
DUBE OVER THE LINE, OUT FOR
MANGIAPANE!
THE EFFORT
BY ANDREW MANGIAPANE JUST TO GET
THE POWER PLAY
ABLE TO SNEAK ONE HAVE
HIS HEAD UP THE ENTIRE AWAY.
HAMPUS LINDHOLM CAN'T GET IT
PAST BACKLUND WHO KEEPS IT ON
GIBSON WAS THERE TO SHUT IT A WT
AND SAVED BY GIBSOSO
STOPPED, REBOUND!
[ Horn Sounding ]IDE LOOKING
[ Cheering ]CORES IN HIS
SECOND CONSECUTIVE GAME.
JUST A REALLY NICE SET SHOT!
MARKSTRÖM MAKES A GOOD SAVE. GI.
PUCK BACK TO HANIFIN,
MANGIAPANE, THE PUY!
MARKSTRÖM FORCED OF JONES
AND OUT SAVE.
ZADOROV FEEDS IT AHEAD,ONOHAN SD
BY GIBSON!
REBOUND, STOPPED THAT TOO OFF OF
MANGIAPANE.
THAT ALL
WHACKS AT THE REBOUND ALSO.
AWAY.O REALLY GOOD PLAYS LED TO
GIBSON GOT THE RIGHT PAD OUT.
HERE ONE.
[ ♪ ]
HE PUCK BEHIND THE
NET,
GOES TO THE LINE, KEPT IT IN,
FIRED A COLEMAN TO DUBE.
H 7:05 TO GO
TIES IT UPACK OUT,
GETS A RETURN LINE.
RASMUS ANDERSSON, TKACHUK'S IN
FRONTERS HERE'S GAUDREAU,ON THEK
AT THENE IS
HEADED OPENER FOR CALGARY.TERRYS
ONE IN OVE